les français sont favorables à
l'affichage sur les plages du degré de
pollution
ils le disent dans une enquête de liffré
ce que france soir a publié ci se veut
était exaucé par toutes les villes
balnéaires la lutte contre la pollution
serait sans aucun doute plus facile les
touristes se rendre compte des dégâts
qu'ils commettent parfois cela les
inciterait à être peut-être un peu plus
propre ce n'est pas toujours le cas
un régal s en est aperçu à port cros où
il a rencontré deux drôles d'éboueurs le
paradis sur terre pas besoin d'aller le
chercher aux marquises envahi par les
moustiques
c'est à port cros en face du lavandou
parc terrestre depuis 63 pour prendre
celle des essences végétales inconnu aux
yeux
on a fait ensuite de lui un parc
national marin le seul en france pour
l'instant une soixantaine d'habitants
l'hiver deux à trois mille touristes
l'été auxquels s'ajoutent les 400
bateaux de plaisance au mouillage ses
adeptes de la navigation n'y vont pas de
main morte
à tel point qu'il a fallu organiser un
système de ramassage des ordures sous
marin juste retour des choses c'est
plaisanciers se baignent dans leur jus
solides ou liquides
et a certainement d'alcool qu'ils
connaissent bien mais le simple fait
d'être sans bateau ici d'estrade c'est
pas tellement bien se conduit en cours
et gifi nos sièges jeu participent
allègrement à l'art mais c'est pas
terrible c'est pas bien ce que nuit et
ce n'est pas tout si la chasse terrestre
ou sous marine est interdite sur et
autour de l'île la pêche est permise
professionnelle ou sportives
décidément un site qui attire beaucoup
de convoitises
autre problème les encres en raclant le
fond dbl font disparaître les possibles
ni ses plantes jouent un rôle important
en méditerranée dans cette mer sans
marais elles fournissent l'oxygène
indispensable à la vie marine
pourquoi on n'est pas polluée cependant
dans certaines baies à certaines heures
du jour pendant certains mourant
l'addition de des plaisanciers
l'addition des retombées organique fait
que certaines bêtes peuvent être
prélevés et même dangereusement pour la
baignade ou pour d'autres le coacher les
deux ans qui les commerçants 12 francs
la bouteille d'eau minérale sur l'île
beaucoup profitent de porco sans en
payer le prix
je gère les profits le parc national les
pertes pour combien de temps encore